c'est prévu alors c'était une personne
que je revoyais adamovich a eu en guise
où la roche actuellement d'accord ouais
et la lyre soit s'est bien terminée ça
s'est bien terminé pas trop tard ça
s'est terminé l'épreuve était de très
bonne ah oui il a fait un petit complet
c'est une marinade que vous avez fait
pendant trois ans mais
non ça s'est bien terminé non c'est un
sénateur qui est qui roule très bien et
c'est une histoire d'amour qui commence
c'est juste comme ça une aventure savez
non bonne il serait content non non non
c'est ça ça commence ça commence
serviront s'apprend mais teheiura
s'apprend comme commun comme un feu dans
koh lanta non qu'on voit comme et les
débuts
ont arrosé qui est qui hier soir il ya
eu papale en papa
la crosse de
[Applaudissements]
leurs bienfaits mais juste avant moi
mais alors tout ça
m
[Applaudissements]
je n'ai pas
aimé du tout
parce que la fed
va pas aider j'ai l'impression qu'il me
respecte plus chez lui lui ce qu'il faut
je pense que seraient ces cas là c'est
comme
ça dans le calme et des petites
dimensions clés le petit chaperon rouge
et robin les basques
n'ont pas dit non vous regardez non non
mais bref c'est bien ah ouais ils
m'aiment bien beaucoup n'ont qu'un petit
peu jaloux non c'est pas vrai les dj no
way oui parce qu'ils pensent que vous
m'aimez bien non mariés qui soit plus
jaloux du tout
je veux bien aller de quoi hier s'il te
plaît dans l'émission comment
merci géraldine mais c'était non c'était
bien c'était c'était
avec loi bien mes films il y avait une
prostituée qui étaient là pour parler
non pas du tout ça signé bernard montiel
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
il est ok
sinon ils tombent nous mettons la
personne ne vient chez nous et la
personne entière de nager les séries et
nijrab à y plonge certain nombre à
mathieu a été franc et nous avons
vérifié enfin à moitié c'est qu'il était
sur un bannière je comprends la
prochaine fois dites moi la vérité ou
maps et m'ont dit tu sur un bail ce soir
j'ai pas envie de faire l'émission
préférée l'absolu on l'avait rêvé de
passer de chauffe prévenait dans
la vérité